tell everybody the story um behind the  uh rock flag an eagle song that became  so iconic i feel like it's a riff that  like hornsby and i had where mourinho  and i would joke about truck commercials  and that they you know they at that time  i don't know if they're still doing this  it seemed like they were just  pumping out the most  they were stereotypical american things  it was like eagles and rocks and it was  just like you know yeah flags flags  flags flying everywhere they're still  doing that so we used to joke around  about like car commercials and you know  like i got rocks and flags and eagles  you know drive a big truck on a kick's  mass whatever but also you know what  mary elizabeth had a really funny one  too  she used to joke  that they would take it as far as like  jesus carrying the cross yeah and then  all of a sudden like a truck comes up  and he like throws the cross in the back  of the truck to take himself up there  was like jesus dress a ford  [Music]